from 1995 to 2001 xena warrior princess
delivered 134 episodes of historical
fantasy with a campy twist
in the years since its finale it's
become a bonafide cult classic
but what has the cast been up to over
the course of the last two decades
we're here to find out though she starts
out as a ruthless warrior
xena's arc bends towards mercy after an
epiphany leads her to seek forgiveness
for the many crimes of her past meeting
the gentle gabrielle
who proves to be the perfect
counterpoint to xena's aggression
certainly helps with a good angel in toe
xena wins her way towards something like
redemption over the course of the show
that's not to say she doesn't do a whole
lot of incredibly cool fighting along
the way of course
after all this isn't a show called xena
peaceful princess
but now xena fights for those who can't
defend themselves over the course of the
series she takes on evil doers of all
kinds
from the pettiest warlords to the
mightiest gods all
in the name of justice xena might live
an active life but
so does lucy lawless the actor who
played her since 2001
in television and film lawless has
racked up an impressive collection of
screen work
she's had significant character arcs on
shows like battle star galactica
the l word spartacus parks and
recreation
and even teamed up with her old xena
co-star bruce campbell in ash vs evil
dead
as for movies lawless has also been seen
in small roles in spider-man
euro trip the changeover and a plethora
of television movies
her next role will be as the voice of
nunchuck in minions
the rise of gru slated for a 2021
release
xena warrior princess set a high bar for
women's representation on screen
take gabrielle played by renee o'connor
she starts her arc on the show as a babe
in the woods type who tempers xena's
bloodier instincts
but as she learns how to fight and
protect others gabrielle grows
changes and discovers entirely new
facets of herself
eventually gabrielle becomes a
celebrated bard
a skilled warrior and an actual amazon
while rene o'connor has continued
working in television since her 134
episode run on xena her career has
stayed relatively low key
o'connor has appeared in a number of
made-for-television movies including
last chance and the horror movies
monster arc
and alien apocalypse on the big screen
o'connor has had roles in ghost town
the movie boogeyman 2 diamonds and guns
and dead rise o'connor's most recent
screen credits are from 2017 where she
starred in the drama
a question of faith and the family
sci-fi movie watch the sky
if you're surprised by the seeming
scarcity of roles on her resume
don't be it's only because o'connor has
shifted from working on the screen to
the stage
she's been in productions of annie uncle
vanya mary poppins
and romeo and juliet over the last few
years earning tremendous acclaim along
the way
sure it might be weird to imagine sweet
gabrielle is the fearsome
lady macbeth but o'connor's skill is
more than enough to make it work
while lucy lawless and rene o'connor
star in every episode of xena
ted raimi's jockster the mighty only
appears in 43 episodes
this might come as a surprise to even
the most seasoned xenophan
such is the strength of raymie's
performance
[Music]
yeah joxer
the mighty at your service
joxer is a wannabe soldier who
accidentally falls in with xena and
gabrielle
who tolerate him in spite of his eternal
incompetence
joxer eventually falls in love with
gabrielle who briefly returns his
affections while under a love spell
but it fades of course and joxer
ultimately marries one of ziena's many
lookalikes
with whom he has many children because
that's just how things roll in the
xenoverse
ted raymie has gone on to have a booming
screen career since xena's end
he's worked as a voice actor in code
monkeys and buddy thunderstruck as well
as landing a list of live action roles
on shows like csi new york
masters of horror and legend of the
seeker he also starred in his brother
sam raimi's ash vs evil dead
alongside two of his zena co-stars lucy
lawless and bruce campbell
but film is where raimi's career has
really taken off
he's been seen in such blockbusters as
all three of his brother sam spider-man
movies
as well as the grudge and the midnight
meat train
like zena ares began as a hercules the
legendary journeys character
played by new zealander kevin smith
smoldering aries is a complicated figure
in this universe
particularly when it comes to xena
herself it is aries that imbues xina
with her violent warrior spirit
and ares with whom she has a complex
romance
he's complicated stormy and played to
perfection by smith
after smith's time on xena he went on to
play the lead role in the tv movie
lawless dead evidence and a short film
called
the meeting smith was also in the 2002
martial arts fantasy film
warriors of virtue 2 returned to tau but
while filming warriors of virtue
smith took a tragic fall from a prop
tower on the set of another film
he passed away at the age of 38. his tv
movie riverworld was released
posthumously in 2003
and is his final film had he lived
smith's next project would have been the
bruce willis action caper tears of the
sun
set to start filming just one month
after his death
as xena's nemesis kalisto hudson leak is
the picture of malice
a survivor of one of zena's past
rampages she lost her village and her
family to the warrior princess's
bloodlust
over the course of 18 episodes kalisto's
sole ambition is to make xena's life
hell
whenever possible kalisto pretends to be
xena for a while
committing new horrible crimes in her
name to stir up public hatred
she even dies multiple times by xena's
hand but
is continually brought back she becomes
a warlord
a demon an angel and even a goddess over
the course of her vengeful
journey hudson league has had a number
of one-off roles in television shows
since her stint on xena
including true calling csi niptuck
shark and law order la she's also been
busy on the film front
booking appearances in the action
thriller coldheart the rom-com
one two many and a noirish mystery
called paris connections
recently however leak's career has
undergone a major change
she now works primarily as a yoga
instructor through her company
healing heart yoga through which she
runs retreats
teaches classes and even does astrology
readings
carl urban's julius caesar is one of
xena's mortal enemies
seriously their first meeting ends in
him breaking her legs and crucifying her
after xena is resurrected her enmity
towards caesar grows until she finally
kills him once and for all
in season four's the ides of march even
that isn't the end for caesar however
he manages to take the fates hostage and
rewrite reality by using their magical
loom
xena saves the day of course but not
before being trapped in an alternate
reality in which she and caesar rule
rome together as
empress and emperor so what's urban been
up to since cena went off the air
the better question is what hasn't he
done urban has had
significant roles in some of the biggest
film franchises of the last couple of
decades
including starring as eomer and the lord
of the rings the two towers and return
of the king
as bones in star trek star trek into
darkness and star trek beyond
and his scourge in thor ragnarok urban
further expanded his superhero resume
as billy butcher on amazon prime's the
boys and had a full season arc as
detective john kennex
an almost human urban has also played
leading roles in dread
the bourne supremacy doom and more
he is set to star in the crime drama
cold providence which goes into
production in 2021
carl urban might not actually be julius
caesar but it turns out that he and
caesar share an unstoppable work ethic
alexandra tiding's aphrodite has a
longer character arc on hercules
but the 11 episodes of xena in which she
appears are still
plenty significant aphrodite is
something of a valley girl in xena
often used for comic relief and
lighthearted looks into the politics of
mount olympus
the love goddess is off the clock i get
my own problems
her arc turns horrifying however when
her brother aries dies and she undergoes
a psychotic break
this results in the total loss of love
in the world as
this emotion cannot exist without the
balance provided by war
naturally xena comes to the rescue by
resurrecting aphrodite and aries
and thus restoring world order as a
screen actor alexandra tidings has been
fairly quiet since xena completed its
run
she has had small roles on the 2001
television show sheena
modern classic the wire in 2008 and a
handful of other shows and tv movies
from 2015 to 2016 she starred in a
number of episodes of the documentary
series from the mouths of
babes in which she discusses her time on
xena
she's also worked as an independent
writer director and producer on a
variety of projects
the trial of hannah porn her 2015 look
at the struggle for reproductive rights
won the best of fringe award at the
charm city fringe festival
while rainbow bridge a short film
covering similar themes was successfully
kick-started in 2017.
many strange characters populate xena's
five seasons but
eve has to be one of the weirdest of
them all
played by adrian wilkinson eva zena's
daughter conceived immaculately to serve
as kalisto's reincarnation after she
becomes an angel
yes really eve is prophesied to be the
bringer of twilight who will end the
reign of the olympian gods
for a huge chunk of eve's life she is
hidden away and or
on the run eventually finding protection
with her birth mother
xena she later becomes a missionary of
eli
the xenoverse's loose take on jesus
christ
actor adrian wilkinson has kept
extremely busy since her 11 episodes as
eve on xena
she has done a great deal of voice
acting for video games including star
wars the force unleashed
command and conquer 3 kane's wrath the
sopranos road to respect
and dead to rights 2. her television
work includes appearances on undressed
as if angel er charmed
and star wars the clone wars she's also
had small roles in movies including
action caper reyes
and more recently appeared in the 2020
horror flick
dreamcatcher wilkinson also wrote
directed
and co-produced the documentary series
from the mouths of babes
in which she interviews many of her xena
co-stars
as ruler of the amazons danielle
cormac's ephony is yet another fierce
and powerful woman of the xenoverse
while she starts out on rocky ground
with both xena and gabrielle
over the course of their shared arc the
women eventually become staunch allies
epheny marries the centaur phantase and
names her child xenon after xena
who performs an emergency c-section
during epheny's childbirth
epheny is tragically killed in battle
protecting her amazonian tribe
and avenged by gabrielle daniel cormack
has added an impressive number of new
zealand and australian tv credits to her
name since appearing on xena
cormac starred in young adult fantasy
madigan's quest
the dramedy rude awakenings crime dramas
the strip and
underbelly drama the cult action
adventure the legend of the seeker
courtroom comedy the rake prison drama
wentworth
crime procedural jack irish and rom-com
fresh eggs more recently she's been
working again with her xena co-star lucy
lawless
on the crime drama my life is murder
a master escape artist autolocus is
characterized by a list of standout
skills and personality traits that
include his deep sense of justice
excellent disguises and can't be flair
he only figures in eight episodes though
he has a longer arc on hercules but boy
does he make those eight episodes count
not only is atolicus an important ally
to xena and gabrielle
he brings a wonderful banter-heavy
comedy to the show that fans still
relish years after the series end
the actor who portrays italicus the
legendary bruce campbell
needs no introduction this star of the
iconic evil dead series created by xena
co-star ted raymie's brother
sam has been a fearsome force in movies
and television for years
campbell has played significant roles on
burn notice
the replacements fargo and the title
role in ash vs evil dead campbell has
also compiled an
impressive roster of voice work that
includes rapunzel's tangled adventure
and cloudy with a chance of meatballs he
also made a cameo in the 2013 evil dead
remake
groovy along with a whole host of
other big and small screen projects
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]